hi my name is Lisa Snell and I'm the
education director at The Reason
Foundation and tonight we are here for
our national school choice week
celebration and it is for national
school choice week which runs January
25th through the 31st and we're going to
have a discussion tonight about a very
important legal case in California
called the Vergara decision and joining
me tonight is a very distinguished panel
of California experts advocates and
plaintiffs in the case first I have Bill
Evers who works at the Hoover Institute
at Stanford and he has a long history in
education reform in the middle I have
Joe and Julia Macias how do you say your
last name I'm sorry my Masius and
marshal tuck who recently ran for state
superintendent and is a longtime
advocate for education reform in
California he worked on school start ups
in Los Angeles Unified and in charter
schools thank you all so much for
joining me tonight I'm gonna start
actually with Julia because I think that
Julia is the star of this show
absolutely so Julia you were a plaintiff
in the Vergara case which I'm actually
going to have you just tell us
succinctly what that meant to you and
what you think the Vergara case was
about just for our panel well the
Vergara case was about making sure every
student voice is heard because every
student has or deserves the right to a
great education leading to a great
success great thank you and Joe can you
tell us from as her dad and from a
parent's perspective you know the
Vergara case actually went over five
laws right but in practice would you
tell us a little bit about what statutes
the regarde case took on and then also
personally what kind of effect it had on
you as a parent and your family this was
was important to us because Julia was
affected by all statutes you know she
you know she was able you know me we saw
great teachers get dismissed because of
the LIFO we we've seen teachers who have
permanent employment even though they're
/ you know they're grossly ineffective
teachers so for us this this case
signifies a lot because we're given a
voice and I think it creates awareness
of the current situation in our school
system great thanks now Marshall at the
time that this case was going forward
you actually were acting as a
spokesperson to become the new state
superintendent and to move the state
toward an education reform agenda do you
mind telling us what do you think the
implications of this will be and what do
you think will actually happen moving
forward now we have a court decision
obviously it's being appealed but what
comes next or what you know in your
vision is likely to happen in the state
of California around these laws case and
first I want to thank Julia and Joe and
Evelyn for really being pioneers and
leading on this you know these statutes
that say that a teacher gets tenure in
less than two years that all layoffs are
done based only on seniority not based
on performance that is virtually
impossible to remove highly ineffective
teachers they've been around for a real
long time
and people have known for a real long
time that they are not good for kids but
it took courageous Julia and Joe and
Evelyn to fight for those rights to
finally push this issue forward and I
just think it's such an important and
monumental working and just a wonderful
act of courage I've been so happy to get
to know you all there in this process
and I think what it means for our state
is that we're not moving backwards on
the issue of what are the best policies
for kids and these are policies that we
know have been highly detrimental
particularly to our highest poverty
children because these policies actually
lead to a situation where you have
larger numbers of gross and effective
teachers in front of often our most
challenging students that have the
greatest need and you also have a
situation where you have somehow the
effective teachers who've been let go
and oftentimes from schools and in my
experience running a number of schools
up and down the state sorry here in Los
Angeles
was we had some wonderful teachers that
came to schools in Watson in East LA
that we had to let go because of the
laws that say last in first now and
what's been fun up and down the state
has been just talking to people in the
public and and we're moving forward and
I think what you're gonna see come out
of the Vergara case our policies that
are good for teachers in terms of making
sure that we are supporting teachers
making sure that we're lifting teachers
up but most importantly are really good
for kids so we don't have policies and
we'll see an appellate court that's hope
we can uphold this law and then the
Legislature will be the ones that decide
what comes next in the law but I think
what you'll see is longer tenure
policies where layoffs are based on
performance not on seniority and also
dismissal process it's much more
rational so if you have grossly
ineffective employees teachers
principals or otherwise that they're
able to be removed quickly rather than
have kids and young people feel the
negative impacts of that which is just
absolutely and positively unacceptable
in our state bill I wanted to ask you
from like a larger worldview perspective
you know one of the criticisms has been
about Vergara about teachers being
judged based on test scores and I wonder
if you would talk a little bit about the
national trend like is it the case now
anywhere in the country that test scores
are the sole way that teachers are
judged or you know the Obama
administration has done a lot of work
around teacher performance you know what
is that trend and what is what do you
think likely is the reality for
evaluating teachers in the United States
moving forward and how does that relate
to the Vergara case well there's no
there's no state where the sole judgment
is the test score and certainly not one
year test score but I don't think we
want to push test scores out of the
picture if they're a rolling
accumulation of a number of years
experience of the teacher with classes
over several years we get a pretty
accurate picture of whether that teacher
is delivering a year's worth of learning
to the child in a year
that if we look at what could help child
succeed if that child gets three years
in a row of underperforming teachers in
terms of their success in getting the
children to learn that can be the end of
their school achievement essentially
they could be ruined for life and this
is a horrible thing to impose on any
anybody and the children from racial
minorities or from low incomes are often
in schools where there are high
concentrations of these underperforming
teachers and this is just a crime to
impose that on those families and those
children so I don't you could
overemphasize testing you could use bad
tests but I think it would be a mistake
if you have fairly good tests and you
looked at across several years to
somehow let the teachers you have only a
subjective judgement of somebody be the
basis of it testing it should be part of
it okay thanks Bill
so here's the thing like Marshall you've
worked in schools and you've had your
family in schools and Bill you have a
lot of experience with schools so I'm
just throwing this out here for the
panel is it the case that we actually in
a lot of cases need tested tests to know
who the low performers are so when I
look through the slides about the
Vergara case a lot of the poor
performance was not planning lessons
absenteeism disorganization like there
already seemed to be a lot of evidence
and you know I have two kids in school
my son just graduated from high school
my daughter's a junior in my experience
the principal the parents the kids like
maybe there's some teachers in the
middle that could go either way but the
the teachers that people are unsatisfied
with it's like an open secret like no
one needs to wait even for a test score
to tell them that because there's other
kinds of competence and behavior that so
Joe how about you guys talk about the
case that you mentioned in the video
right like to have a teacher tell you
when your child is in second grade that
they'll never be able to do math
I mean that's an indicator that you know
you don't need a test to tell you that
it's your personal interaction with the
teacher so in a way it's almost like
test scores are a strawman because it's
not like in schools people don't have an
indication already of who might be
they're low performers and maybe tests
would confirm that but so Joe do you
want to talk a little bit about your
personal experience with that I think I
believe that test scores are an
indicator where your student you know
obvious the student level of achievement
or understanding in that subject matter
so they serve as a guide I also feel
that your test courts serve as a as a
benchmark for the teacher to see how
effective they are teaching within the
classroom and for for me as a parent who
is not there in the classroom I do see
these test scores as an indicator of how
much of how well my my my daughter is
doing in the classroom and in the in the
school so definitely I'm a strong
believer in in the antis course sitter
the fact that my friend Rick and Scheck
who's an economist who studies education
has said that if we could dismiss move
to some other occupation the five
percent lowest performing teachers in
our public schools that and put in
average teachers in their place the
United States would be the top
performing country in the world now part
of the problem is many people feel the
political heat of firing somebody and so
as you saw in the video then numbers are
minuscule it's like no other profession
imagine GE Jack Welch used to say I fire
5% of the people every year who are the
lowest performers think you know and and
Hannah shek is not talking about every
year he's to sing one time firing the
laws so in regular life people are fired
all the time
and it's healthy they go on to something
better and the MP does a better job so
we are sacrificing the future of our
children for these adults who have these
protected positions it's not fair it's
not decent for these children these
these adults could do something better
and more productive you said one I think
far too often the conversation on data
and testing goes right to using the data
to remove poor performing teachers
whether reality is is you want the data
to actually help teachers get better at
their jobs and you want the data bill
that if I what teachers are doing very
well so you can learn from them and
share those best practices without
actually having information you're not
able to actually identify what's working
well and frankly if you don't have
feedback as a professional teacher
principal you know regardless of what
your role is you can't actually get
better and so I think it's something
that having good information how
students are achieving is the anchor of
helping a staff improve as fast as
possible the second thing I will mention
to the point of why you do need some
kind of third-party information is you
know there are actually a lot of
principals that aren't very effective
you know we took over the lowest
performing schools in Los Angeles and
and it was amazing I talked to teachers
who hadn't had a principal in their
classroom in two years you know it's at
so many schools so you have to you can't
just assume that a principal is going to
be able to make the right decisions I
mean certainly a high quality principal
will but unfortunately in particular on
high poverty neighborhoods you don't
have that as well and so we have a lot
of issues that need to be addressed in
order to be able make sure that every
child like Julia is getting a high court
education which is there right and as
what is essential for our state so to
follow up on that Marshall in a lot of
newer charter schools now they actually
are using data so much more often so
that they have almost a competency-based
learning so that the data is what tells
them that students are mastering
material and it's not punitive it's a
way to move the class forward it's a way
to individualize instruction for each
child
I mean data in a lot of ways in these
new models is our friend right and can
you talk a little bit about kind of the
trends in blended learning or different
kinds of schools that use data
absolutely I mean it's it's exciting
when you think about the future of what
when you kind of combine a teacher who
supported who is given time for
profession vuelven who believes in their
kids with wonderful kids who want to
learn and then leveraging technology to
really allow you to be able to identify
the unique needs of each child and
what's schools are complicated but
they're pretty simple it's a person from
a classroom trying to understand what
inspires the 30 children in front of me
how does each child actually learn
individually what are the unique
strengths of those child of those
children what are areas where they come
up short where they need additional
support that's really the job and that's
actually why it's so hard so what's nice
about using technology and in dated
information it really allows a teacher
to have such a better understanding of
where their students are at it allows
you to actually have a class of 30 kids
who may be quite different levels of
quite different learning styles and
break them in a much smaller group so
they're able to move forward and you
know example in our schools we took over
when I was at the partnership for Lea
schools Ritter elementary school in
watts and this is the lowest performing
Elementary School in all of LA and we
took it over we worked with a math
program st math it's a great visual math
program and you walk into a kindergarten
classroom every child is on a computer
the teachers walking around as a coach
working with each child individually the
screens are very different because the
kids are at actually different levels
and you're seeing young people just
learning math and falling in love with
it at a very young age and you can track
it all so they're at home morning
weekend's the amount of time they're
actually spending on the subject cuz
it's fun it's kind of game based
mathematics and you're really able to
understand each child's where they're at
and also again for helping our teachers
and principals and counselors get better
at their jobs the data helps them
reflect and learn and grow and so I
think that you're gonna see over the
next five years and ten years just a
wonderful advancement the scary part I
think for the collective state and
country is you're seeing some schools
now really embracing change in
technology while a majority of schools
particularly high poverty neighborhoods
are not and and if we don't get our act
together soon and make sure that all
schools are moving forward we're gonna
see an achievement gap get wider than
it's ever been before because you're
seeing some schools really embrace what
does it take for high quality teacher in
every classroom how do we really engage
and leverage
technology how to make sure teachers are
supported have enough time for
professional element and other schools
aren't and that that's going to be scary
if we don't get our act together the
good news is we will but but we have to
get serious about moving because change
is coming in schools fast make sure it's
coming in all schools in all
neighborhoods for all kids great
so I'm Anna asbill a little bit about
the implications of the regard decision
for the rest of the country and then Joe
and Julia I'm gonna ask you to talk a
little bit about how you've chosen
schools for your girls and for your
family and how you pick the school you
go to and what is the importance of
school choice for you your family so
bill you want to talk a little bit about
what do you think comes next or what is
the significance of this decision that
takes on these teacher rules these work
rules so I would first add though
something about the value of technology
and that also is that parents can learn
more about what's going on with their
child so if you think earlier days you
got a report card maybe every semester
you can communicate and much closer to
real time with the parents you can have
a much more meaningful parent-teacher
conference in on with you know here's
what to watch for in the homework and
here's what to make sure the child
anything you can do to support your
child at home and getting this topic
down solidly so the central question
here is what does this mean nationally
this decision in California and I think
it's extremely important because the
basic problems where teachers get tenure
too early for the instead of three to
five years as say Arnold Schwarzenegger
tried to do in California and even
though these unions apparently privately
acknowledged and this lawsuit they know
that actually makes sense they fought
like crazy against this much more
logical thing when it was on the ballot
in California but anyway so they should
it should be if you're gonna have tenure
it should be a longer time to see if the
teacher is really prepared to do this as
their profession if you're gonna be in a
position of needing to fire in effect
teachers not just teachers that steal
embezzle from the funds of the school or
something like that which even so could
take three years and hundreds of
thousands of dollars if you're gonna do
it though they didn't give them a year's
worth of learning in a year or maybe
they maybe they long you know they lost
significantly progress some how this
happen this happens and if you when when
the school is facing layoffs if it's
done on the basis of seniority if it's
done on the basis of last in first out
you're gonna lose immensely talented
teachers many of which may have had
training in the latest things such as
how to use technology effectively you're
gonna lose those people so you have the
same problem all over the country and
that's why the video lists all these
states now in New York it's going to get
a lot more attention because we have the
former CNN television personality
Campbell Brown heading up the effort to
fight this in New York State and so
we're going to see this in a number of
states but because major news media are
based in New York and because it's a
huge state and this will be a battle of
the Titans in New York and so California
has really led the way the plaintiffs
have led the way the whole family and so
I think it's a it's it's it's of course
of great symbolic importance to the
morale of the school reform movement but
it's of immense practical importance
going forward if the chance for learning
can get liberated if the opportunity for
learning can get liberated so that we
can get people who are ineffective as
teachers to go into other fields and
stop holding back kids who could be
advancing who could be achieving their
potential thanks so much bill so Julia
tell me a little bit about where you go
to school now and how you got there did
you did your family choose that school
and what does that choice mean to you
well I'm currently attending a magnet
school focusing on
you know literature and like global
social institutions etc and my parents
did help me through the way through my
education helping me to get to where I
am now my level of education overall and
definitely my parents have been a really
big role and they've advocated for me
like a long part of doing the entire
journey and it's just been an they're
really inspiring and they definitely do
play a big role in my education which is
why they have helped me to get to where
I am today thank you and Joe you want to
talk a little bit about how you chose
schools for your kiddos yes and doesn't
you bring up school choice because you
know doing advocacy for education reform
for us as a family has been in the
making you know for the past over you
know over 10 years and I think to be to
really be able to implement that into
looking out for our kids and make sure
they that they get the best education
possible is especially important now one
recommendation that you know you know
that we that I do want to give is for
parents to really be involved and know
visit the schools talk to the principals
talk to talk to other parents with had
kids there that's how we we get to find
out the ins and the outs of the schools
and also discuss these findings with
your kids
Julia selected the school because she
had you know she had a choice of going
to three different schools and whatever
what are her interest and that helped us
as a guide to selecting the right school
for her and it and also what her
long-term goals in her case she wants to
go to to Harvard or MIT and you know how
are we gonna get her there are these
teachers going to prepare her and get
her ready for those schools and so you
know we have to do extra research as
parents and be more aware of the things
that are
taking place in the school in the
schools by getting involved in in the
the parents groups and and as well as
keeping up with the grades and asking
those questions to the teachers so for
us school choice has been important and
work a lot that you know we have it here
and we hope that this case you know
helps us with more school choice because
I don't want to be afraid of next year
then my daughter will be in a classroom
with an ineffective teacher that is not
going to prepare her to get her into the
College of her choice I completely agree
with you that a parent who wants success
for his child or her child has to do
this extra effort but actually we should
look forward to a world where not it
doesn't happen to be like a full-time
occupation of a parent to try to
navigate the school system it should be
easier to pick it to have consumers
reports of Education and things like
that and you could choose a variety of
pluralism of options that were more
readily available you didn't have to be
spending all your time learning how to
navigate this bureaucracy
it's instead like other things other
services that you obtain in life and
it's fairly easy it still doesn't mean
you shouldn't put effort into it but it
doesn't have to consume your life and I
completely agree that the teacher of all
the different things that affect the
success of a child
the teachers oh my wife my wife is here
in the audience on a bryson and she was
on school board in Southern California
for eight years and that district made a
huge effort to get high quality teachers
and to nudge out teachers that were not
being successful but not every district
does that is a dangerous tricky thing to
do and it's politically volatile and one
of the reasons that tests are there in a
sense is that if they do have the
intestinal fortitude too tired to fire a
teacher and it then gets to a lawsuit
they can point to the tests and they can
say look this teacher was not succeeding
with the students and it's not just
somebody's opinion
here's the hard evidence so that's
something that can be turned back to
absolutely Marshall to kind of wrap
things up will you tell us a little bit
about the parent revolution the parent
trigger some of the parent groups like
what are things that parents can do
right now in California in LA to get
involved what have been some of the
successes of these efforts of parents to
get more choices and to change the
quality of their schools yeah absolutely
and I kind of took Tibbals point what do
you want a parent to be able to do you
want a parent to be able to you know I
have a three and a half year old sons my
wife and I started talk about his
kindergarten he's in preschool right now
and I want to know what are all the
schools in my neighborhood
how are those schools doing if there are
issues who can follow up with I want to
have choice and I want to actually have
I want to be a part of it I want to do
my part I have a responsibility as a
parent it's not just a school I have a
responsibility and then also I'll make
sure we can hold schools accountable so
we can all learn together and make sure
that there's a wonderful place for my
son to be loved and cared for and so he
can learn and grow into whoever he's
going to grow into and unfortunate that
doesn't exist and in particular in our
state doesn't exist for families that
are where parents are less educated and
typically doesn't exist for many
families that are you know in in the
most impoverished neighborhoods and that
has to change what's nice is you are
seeing more and more opportunities in
more and more groups and more more
policy that's giving parents real power
in the equation so one law that was
passed called a parent empowerment act
which the parent revolution is a group
that helped pass that and was former
senator Romero push the bill through and
it basically said that if parents are if
a school is failing and parents are
frustrated then 50% of those parents
actually sign a petition they can change
that school and force it to be
reconstituted force to become a charter
and it was the first time you actually
saw real power put in the hands of
parents the other thing which is
wonderful is you know you have charter
school options where parents can and for
the first time when to me the beauty of
there's a lot of things that are
beautiful about charter schools but what
I love the most is that it actually for
the first time gave families of poverty
choice which frankly upper middle-class
and upper-class has always had you know
upper class choices private school live
in a neighborhood good public schools
and high poverty FEMA has never had that
I think as bill mentioned the key is
what you want to see school districts in
the state move forward on is make sure
that parents know in a simple digestible
easy way easily accessible for all
classes all education levels what are
all my school options
how are those schools doing and how do I
help find the right match for my child
and then you do see other organizations
and the partnership for those schools
which I used to lead we ran a parent
college on Saturdays 8 a.m. to 2 p.m.
our schools were all in the highest
pavan errors at neighborhoods of LA
where we taught our parents two things
we had an academic track and an
empowerment track one was how do I be
better parents for your children's
education because a lot of parents just
didn't know how to do the X they had
their with low education levels you know
new to this country etc and second was
our empowerment track what are your
rights as a parent and and how do you
push this system to drive change and the
last thing I'll say which is always
critical and it's very relevant coming
out of my experience from a couple
months ago as parents have to vote
because parents are the natural
counterbalance to special interests in
education they are the natural
counterbalance with a vested interest
and if we do not vote for the school
board if we do not vote for the
legislature if we don't vote for the
State Superintendent we will have the
same situation today from a policy
perspective sorry tomorrow that we have
today but if we actually step up
exercise our rights with our kids
directly but then also make sure all of
us even if we are not parents today of
children in school we got to take care
of other people's children because
they're all our children get active
politically to make sure these things
happen and then support you know the
legal channel which Vergara was just
wonderful at because politics wasn't
working as well the drive is much
changed it's very simple question what
is the best policy for children if this
was my child what would I want for that
child that's that's what we need to move
forward on and the nice part is there's
more avenues for parents to do that
today and something I wanted to add
something about the parent power through
parent revolution and through the
trigger laws the parent trigger laws and
this is a sort of an analytic point that
not everybody realizes but if you
normally are a pair
and you try to set a charter school up
you might be put in a lottery and even
if you did tons of work for getting this
charter created your own child might not
be able to be in it but the thing that
happens with the parent trigger is you
are getting together with all these
other parents and you know that you will
be part of it so you have the motivation
to do effective work to help your child
because you know you have it once you
get to this threshold your kid's gonna
get the benefit and you don't the other
way so it it leads you to maybe sit back
and let somebody else do it and hope you
win the lottery but it doesn't motivate
you to participate and this is a way
that motivates you to work for your
child's success thank you okay I'm gonna
say one reason that vergara is so
personally important to the work that I
do and then we're going to take
questions from the audience so at The
Reason Foundation we're getting ready to
launch a new school choice center called
the Center for school funding
portability and it's going to focus on
all kinds of school choice but one of
the areas that there's less research on
is the idea that students should have
their per pupil funding from the local
state and federal in a backpack that
goes to the school that they enroll in
and that's what happens with charter
schools I mean it's not as much money in
the backpack as a traditional public
school but if you enroll in a charter
school the funding follows you to that
school and it goes directly to the
school but in regular public schools
that are run by school districts there's
a lot of money chopped up off the top
before that money follows you to the
school and there's a lot of rules
attached to that money so most school
districts in the United States give
principal staff so you get so many
adults for so many kids they have a lot
of rules about who you hire and how and
the individual principal doesn't
necessarily get access to the budget so
the reason that vergara is important is
right now there's about 20 school
districts around the country that have
student based budgeting or student based
allocation where all the public schools
can
heat for the public dollars and they
have open enrollment and the money
actually does follow the kids to the
school and a principal gets to make a
decision but what they don't have so
they have autonomy over the money but
then they still have to follow all of
these rules so if I am a principal and I
get control of 80 percent of my budget
but somebody tells me that when we have
to do layoffs at the district I have to
get rid of these teachers first or they
tell me that I have forced placement and
I have to take this teacher or that I
have to follow these tenure rules and
give permanent employment to teachers I
know that aren't ready for that it
doesn't do me very much good to have
control of my budget or to have school
choice if I still have to follow all
these legal rules about who I can hire
so vergara is very very significant to
the student based budgeting move and
there's a lot of districts that have
done this like Boston and Baltimore and
LA Unified actually has a hundred
schools that are funded this way it's
not as robust as some other places but
they try so but around the country we're
really moving toward largely because of
the 6500 charter schools that are funded
this way they put a lot of pressure on
traditional districts to give their
principals the money in the autonomy and
I can guarantee you without the 6500
charter schools there wouldn't be in a
district in America that would give any
principals any more autonomy they'd
still tell them exactly what to do but
so for the work that we're doing moving
forward a piece of giving more school
choice more autonomy is relaxing the
rules that the Vergara case relaxed and
so thank you so much for being a
plaintiff in the case Julia and for all
the work because it's going to make the
work that we do here at The Reason
Foundation and help us to move forward
policies that will give kids more school
choice and higher quality teachers and
now we will take any questions that you
guys have can I ask you to I think I'll
repeat the question so if you can talk
loudly but then I'll just repeat it so
that we can get it for the panel
please
they didn't argue the merits
okay
okay so the question is could we at this
time have another initiative so as a
large state vote right on the rules in
this case so about ten year life oh all
of these different rules that the
Vergara case took on so let's start with
Joe any thoughts about that do you think
that that might work or I like I
particularly like the process we're
taking now because this process really
makes each individual look at what has
what has been decided at the lower the
lower case I mean lower courts and there
isn't any money so in one way or another
but just the actual facts of what this
case was about so for me it would be
more more important to create awareness
and the importance of the these statutes
that are in place and how this case
would make it better in the sense of for
the schools or for the for those
principles that run those schools as
opposed to an initiative Marshall is
that there's an appellate court case I
mean ruling coming this summer and I
think that it's a better chance of
getting these laws passed to let that
play out hopefully that actually they
continue to support the law and then I
think the legislature doesn't if they
try to kind of backdoor a deal that get
around it to make it a little bit better
than I think that you're in a better
place from an earned media and an
outraged perspective to after this
process plays out if they still don't
fix the laws to run initiative you know
probably like in a 2018 timeframe
because you'd have a case where courts
support it maybe the legislature doesn't
do the right work and tries to kind of
get around by passing laws that are
mildly better but not substantially by
then I think you'd see even more outrage
publicly and probably increase the
chances of winning versus running the
initiative before the court case is
played out I think that there's from a
political perspective that the court
case play out and then if there's a
pushback if we don't get there I hope we
get there I think the hopefully the
governor will lead us there but if we
don't get there I think
we're in a better position to actually
win an initiative after is my sense just
from a straight you know political
calculation I would agree with Marshall
I do think it's helpful though to do
things not just through the courts but
through other methods like the
legislature and the which is very
impossible right now but also other
other things that are the referendum and
Alyssa Tory things because it engages
people and they get they have to learn a
little bit about it in order to help
make decisions I would add to your thing
about portability that the governor in a
sense legitimized this with his funding
formula but he bowed to the union's on
having the money go to the central
headquarters and not be truly in a
backpack as much as my wife used to say
in the campaign that she ran earlier
last year and that this was a sort of a
robbery for these children and that they
did then put in some bureaucracy of you
have to report back after you maybe miss
spent all the money what fake categories
you did to end up supporting the status
quo so it's not really a backpack and
that's what you're pushing for and I
think that is a truly noble endeavor the
backpack has to go to the school level
to be like charter schools I mean it is
a public school charter suspended
district headquarter okay I see a
question in the back
you take the child with you and your
daughter for doing that that's that's
your role and that's great but has
either resources or the access or the
time they're working two jobs or
whatever to be that advocate so that's
one issue we're facing in public
education attempts need to get more
support to be involved frankly more
supporting friends like you that'd be
one of the solutions to some of the
problems but I was so impressed tenure
permanency took me three years when I
got reminiscing but at nine this means
that I can advocate for students without
fear one day my principal said you're
out of here and that's one thing that
giving me a permanent position some
lifetime position for me it's been
lifetimes because I love doing it I'm
talking about 37 years I'm talking about
common areas special in students and
having a permanent position allows you
to speak up and advocate for children
and not just go along with everything is
passed down the pike because all the
stuff comes along they do directed to do
it you can speak up when you have a
permanent position like can any job so I
think if you'll talk about the poverty
with paying my first when I first
posture every student in the serving
class but in the first grade level
coming to school there were done
prepared we don't give you know so child
care the month of things basting and I
feel like this when you're talking a lot
of loaded words and they need a brush
are all these teachers that are in
confident not every teacher is gonna
reach your daughter doesn't mean they're
confident every teacher and these
different people
sometimes and I'm all for improving
education I just don't know that what
you're advocating getting rid of
seniority tenure changing tenure
yes I've no problem making three years
maybe five years maybe seven years you
need good administrators in there who
have time to go and look at the children
because I agree to something saying here
that principal should be in classrooms
all the time but the reality is long as
elementary schools especially they have
one principal who has a thousand things
to do
and can't make it it should not be a
surprise to see a principal in your
classroom they should be there they
should know what's going on I agree with
all this so bothersome you're saying I
agree with but I don't know that the
what you're taking on is going to make
that change okay I'm going to stop you
there thank you thank you very much and
I'm gonna let the panel respond to that
bill you know you make a lot of
excellent points it would be much better
if all parents were involved in a great
way but you also pointed out many times
they have a personal situation with how
much income they have to put together
maybe two people are working and so
forth so that's an excellent point but I
think it's sort of like a doctor a
doctor has a patient and the patient
might be a child whose parents are not
spending enough time with that child on
nutrition or whatever whatever it is
the child has problems the doctor takes
the patient as he finds the patient and
he his job or her job is to get a well
child and your job all of us in the
noble profession of teaching I have
taught college myself is to advance the
learning of these children to help them
fulfill their potential they have to put
in some effort too so I think you know
it's important to realize the
difficulties but not to paralyze us and
say gosh we can't get anywhere with
these kids because they come from
low-income households and sometimes this
is the danger of the tyranny of low
expectations people give up on children
they sort of throw in the towel we
can't have that we need a dynamic system
that's encouraging everybody the child
the parent the teacher the administrator
to get everybody moving up or Joe well
first of all this case is not against
teachers I think what we don't want to
remove tenure
we're only questioning how tenure is
obtained whether the the time that that
that teachers get tenured is is the
right amount of time to get someone in
there like you mentioned you've been
teaching for 37 years and we are for
teachers I mean our school system has
some of the greatest teachers and that
what this case is about is addressing
those grossly ineffective teachers that
still like that exist in our district
and I think the teachers know it the
parents know it the principals know it
but their arms are tied in terms of how
to address it and the current the
current law that we have on how they
address them you saw the statistics out
of 275 thousand it was 2,000 students
it's gonna be teachers only two teachers
get removed for not doing their job and
I know their margin nothing so I feel
that this case this case starts
addressing that and makes us talk about
it because by doing so we'll have better
students that have better success in
life and we'll have better teachers in
our school system that are there you
know that want to be there as opposed to
just being there and relying on our
statues to in a sense to protect them
against any type of evaluations thank
you because I want to clarify certainly
this panel is not saying that the only
issue are these statuettes north at the
vergara lawsuits gonna actually improve
all schools in California more we're in
a situation right now as a state where
we have two and a half million kids that
can't read and write a grade level and
there are a number of issues
the reasons why our schools are
successful you know incredible diversity
a lot of poverty in the state is a real
issue it's harder you know it's harder
for a child in intense poverty with
intense challenges and more at least
more expensive maybe to educate then
than for my child that's just it's just
kind of reality of it a lot of left
daycare for our young people we have
funding issues in this state kids aren't
actually in many cases spent enough time
in school there are a whole number of
issues that lead to us not having what
we should have which is a great school
for every child in every neighborhood
that being said I think it's our
responsibility any issue that we can
change that can improve kids lives and
improve schools we have to actually
change it and in this case with there's
no question than a two-year tenure
system and I agree with Joe I support a
longer tenure system not no tenure
system but a two-year tenure system is
just not it's not effective for kids
because you end up having teachers to
get tenure that shouldn't get it a
system that actually says all layoffs
are done based on seniority only and not
based on performance is a system that
guarantees that some children will have
a teacher that is less effective than a
teacher who got laid off because the
structure so I think it's just about how
do we address every issue this just
being one of them and by no means the
only answer in terms of what we need to
do improve our schools and thank you by
the way for 37 years of forcing and I
believe in and focusing on kids I'm
gonna take a question from Manny and
very quick fire a teacher of the year
because they haven't been there that
long that's just a terrible thing for
the children that could have had this
fabulously performing teacher absolutely
Manny and then I'll go over here
we're an SFI what I've the example with
the charter schools and other
experiments that we choice in other
states not just California with green
dot and do the work that you
accomplished but they teachers union as
well it's a battle for survival for them
they have a lot of war chest they were
able there was one early success the
early 90s as the result of the
competition of lost that provided for
educational choice in California it went
down without spending to the one but
that created the first charter schools
the organization in response the
Democrats feared that they would be no
response I mean if I win I'm I'm curious
to ask Marshall you've been in the trip
for a long time on the front lines in a
alternative system a system that is much
more like uber and it is like like young
with the IRS and I be curious what is
your sense of
thing I believe strongly is I think that
the flexibility that charter schools
have should be given to all public
schools traditional public schools so I
think one of the problems we're having
as somebody who's run a school system
that was a charter school system that
had flexibility from this huge I mean
California with this book called the
California Education Code it's 2300
pages it's just filled with rules that
are exhausting for principals and for
teachers and they're brutal that the
charter schools have flexibility for
most of that and so when people would
talk about a charter versus traditional
district I would just say let's just get
the same flexibility at traditional
districts where the dollars follow the
student where principals have much more
flexibility to be successful and when
you're not just completely burdened by
all these rules from the state and I
think by doing that you would actually
unlock an incredible mint of energy and
creativity amongst teachers and
principals who and superintendent
there's not one superinten in the state
that I've talked to who says I would
love to have the same flexibility as
charter schools to more effectively run
my schools and so I think that that's
something that we can push to it I think
it's possible not today because the
political environment you mentioned but
but not too far in the future like I
came out of my campaign very optimistic
you know we ran against an incumbent
supported by the most powerful force in
California politics with an aggressive
effort by the machine to keep that
person in place and we got 48% of vote
and I think with a little more time
little more money would have actually
put it over the top and our coalition
was Republican Democrat independent high
poverty high income just a bunch of
people who wanted to do better by kids
and so I actually think that were it's
going to still be a long a long push but
we're getting to the point where you
have a majority of Californians who are
ready to take action and I think that
charter schools have given a path in
terms of with more flexibility from the
government with more responsibility or
support and frankly respect to the
educators which is one thing that that
environment provides that we can do
better by our kids it doesn't mean all
charter schools are good by the way
because if you can have a good
governance structure if your principal
isn't very good if your principals not
in classrooms if your teachers aren't
actually working to get better every day
you're not kind of a grade school but at
least gives us a better chance to be
more successful so I'm actually quite
optimistic a lot of work to be done
quite realistic about we got a status
quo that's gonna fight tooth and nail to
keep power and not that they're evil
they just are used to a system that
doesn't work and and the system has to
change as you mentioned
but man we got 500,000 kids in charter
schools I saw some incredible public
schools over the last year and not just
you know not just charters even some
traditional publics it's just some
wonderful schools we walk out and say
California can be number one again
there's no question but we got some real
work to do but I'll tell you you know
you get inspired every day by you look
at what Julie is going through and
you're just like hey you know we can do
this and we can make this happen it was
funny I'm looking at the Macias is
parent engagement they're here they're
advocating and Lucy's doing her homework
over here in the front row by the way
while we're at this thing you talk about
you know what's possible good parenting
and also I think good inspiration so I
had the luck of seeing being inspired by
so many people and we're gonna we're
gonna get there because our kids deserve
it and they can get there you know and
our educators deserve it too frankly I
think that I think though that many
Klausner is making an additional point
which is well I concur with everything
marshals has said that you can sometimes
make advances at times when it might
seem like you lost for example we might
lose this appeal but nonetheless the
fact that this has gone so far will mean
that future politicians who were also
scared by marshal tux very powerful
campaign and the support he gathered
against the establishment candidate
they're going to be scared so just as
charter schools came in for fear that
vouchers which are even more empowering
for parents are opportunity scholarships
if they had come in then the special
interests would have been threatened
even further so we may get additional
flexibility out of you know trying to
have something maybe less than what we
got in this great decision but they want
to maybe take the wind out of a future
lawsuit that might again try this so and
that if there were defects let's say in
this case that as judge discovers
somebody might try again not having
those defects so they might try to make
some changes anticipating that so I
think that the point that he's making
and we also see that charter schools
have charter school effects they can
improve the surrounding public schools
because they're challenged they have to
compete just as opportunity scholarships
or vouchers have a so-called voucher
effect the the other schools are worried
about losing the kids the kids exiting
to go somewhere else so there is even
dark clouds can have a silver lining so
keep fighting everybody absolutely so
we're gonna take one final question and
then there'll be an opportunity to talk
after the panel and we're going to let
Julia's mom Evelyn ask that question
especially I want to share with you you
know we didn't really say that julia has
had a wonderful journey and that she's
had amazing teachers who even when she's
had ineffective teachers who have helped
her and second grade it was really hard
but we had a great teacher who helped us
through that process and she was left
out the next year because of life loss
and she was really loved in the school
we get to fourth grade she says mom are
not learning for a 4th grader to tell
the parent mom I'm not learning and we
have to I beat my dog to go sit in the
class and kind of figure out what's
going on and I realized she's not
learning and I talked to the teacher and
I don't get solution and I talked to
several people and I have to move her
when she's been at that schools in
kindergarten with all her friends and
she's getting ready to go to 5th grade
because she doesn't know what she needs
to know and I know she's a year away
from going to middle school we get to
another school and she's got a
phenomenal teacher who helps her catch
up in another year and a half and then
he's let go he's face lifts and then we
get 6th grade and we get another
ineffective teacher and this is math and
we get seventh grade and she we share
the whole situation and she's getting
ready to go to high school and the
teacher says you know I'll teach her
hold her back a year because I heard the
teacher in eighth grade
the spaming students so we hold her back
in pre-algebra gets to eighth grade
guess what she gets that same teacher so
by now we realize what that teacher is
about we speak to the principal and
thank goodness for the principal he gets
Julia in another classroom with the
chair of the of the math department
and she looks at you is just that I
don't know what the problem is she's a
great math student but but like mr. ever
said you know it takes a parent it
it's not about poverty you know poverty
is not the issue for us but it's been so
strenuous having every year to do what
to miss said is like a lottery are we
gonna get an effective teach are we not
gonna get an effective teacher I believe
that now Julia is at a phenomenal high
school and I believe that her middle
school was a phenomenal school with
amazing teachers I mean her signs three
signs features six Anthony grade
inspired her she wants to go into
physics and it's because of those
amazing teachers it's not poverty Joe
and I were teachers assistants in one of
the poorest schools one of the poorest
districts when we were in college and we
saw amazing teachers do phenomenal
things with these kids who were so poor
but we also saw the opposite and I think
too many times poverty can be an excuse
and and I think we shouldn't get stuck
in that I think we really need to look
at the hard facts like mr. ever says
like Marshall says like we've seen we
think scores are are important because
we've been able to see the ups and the
downs and Julia according to the teacher
that she's had and we're not a lower
where were thousands of parents strong
but I think we need to be better
informed I think we need to be more
fearless I think we need to listen to
our children and and I think we need the
unions
to us this isn't a fight with the unions
or the teachers we love the teachers who
need the union's to work with them so if
you can talk about how you can see the
unions working with it I'd like to hear
them have that as a private conversation
I'm not sure that we can answer whether
the unions will work with us but I thank
you so much and I think the bottom line
is it just shouldn't be this hard
it shouldn't be this difficult to find
good schools for our kids and we
shouldn't you know we pick things like
insurance or our cell phones or our cars
you know these are things we spend a lot
of money on and it's so much easier and
then when it comes to education we have
to be constantly vigilant and I don't
think that that vigilance is ever going
to go away but it should work more like
other things education should and we
should have more choices and we should
be able to get through it easier thank
you guys all so much for joining us
tonight and you know I hope there's more
food and drink out there and please
enjoy a few more minutes and you can
also talk to the panel thank you
you